हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है?
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है। अगर आप
लोगों को मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है तो
प्लीज चैट में बता दीजिए।
गाइस आई एम ऑडिबल
प्लीज जल्दी से मुझे चैट में बता दीजिए।
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है।
ओके अममान शेख वेरी गुड इवनिंग। तो क्या
आपको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
बिल्कुल लाउड एंड क्लियर
ओके थैंक यू तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं 1
मिनट का बाकी स्टूडेंट्स को आने देते हैं
उसके बाद क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं। ठीक
है तब तक के लिए अगर प्रीवियस क्लास
रिलेटेड कोई भी किसी का डाउट है तो मुझसे
पूछ सकता है अभी तक ओनली ओके जगत गुरु जी
हर हर महादेव बबलू कुमार
ओके थैंक यू
चलो मेरे ओल्ड स्टूडेंट्स जो कंटीन्यूसली
मेरी क्लास के साथ जुड़े हुए हैं उनको
अगेन
थैंक यू फ्रॉम माय हार्ट
बिकॉज़ आप लोग हमेशा इस क्लास में आते हो,
कंट्रीब्यूट करते हो और कुछ ना कुछ नया
सीखते हो।
थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं क्योंकि अभी
स्टूडेंट्स अभी तक नहीं आए हैं क्लास में।
पता नहीं कहां पर गुम हो गए।
आप सबको मेरी आवाज तो आ ही रही होगी। सबको
सुनाई भी दे रहा होगा तो और वीडियो भी
क्लियर दिखाई दे रही होगी। कोई बफरिंग कुछ
भी नहीं होगा ना इशू।
देयर आर ओनली 10 स्टूडेंट
क्या हो गया? अटेंडेंस बहुत कम आ रही है।
आप लोगों का फेवरेट नहीं है क्या? यह जो
टॉपिक आप लोगों का फेवरेट नहीं है
यस। हेलो
मुझे लगता है आप लोगों का फेवरेट टॉपिक
नहीं है।
थैंक यू जगत गुरु जी अगर आप लोगों को इतना
अच्छा लगता है तो थैंक यू वेरी मच तो देयर
आर ओनली 10 स्टूडेंट पता नहीं कितनी देर
में और स्टूडेंट आएंगे क्योंकि पता नहीं
लोग कहां रहते हैं आज तो सैटरडे है वैसे
भी
ओके अगर आप 35 वीडियो में हो तो फिर भी आप
एक काम कर सकते हो लाइव क्लास देखते रहिए
अच्छा रहेगा
देखिए डिपेंड्स ऑन यू ट्रोजन गेमर कि आप
क्या सीखना चाहते हो बट पेन टेस्टिंग में
तो बग बंटी में जो भी कुछ कवर होता है वह
भी पार्ट होता है पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग का
और जो हम अभी भी कर रहे हैं यह भी
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग का ही पार्ट है।
चलिए अब हम सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं।
ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करने वाले। मुझे
पता है क्योंकि स्टूडेंट्स उतने ही आने
वाले हैं जितने आते हैं। तो इट्स ओके। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। तो वन डे यू रियलाइज कि
आप लोगों ने क्या चीज मिस की है। क्योंकि
जब इसका एग्जाम आएगा ना तो जो हम
सर्टिफिकेशंस पे प्लान कर रहे हैं और जब
इसका हम एग्जाम लेंगे जो पेड एग्जाम होगा
और जिसका कंपटीशंस मार्केट में रहेगा और
जिसको आप यूज़ कर पाओगे और कम पैसों में और
लेवल वही रहेगा क्योंकि सेम फीलिंग, सेम
आपकी जो बोले कि उसको अटेंड करने का
तरीका, सेम टाइम सब कुछ लगभग वही मैच होने
वाली है। तो तब उस दिन आपको पता चलेगा कि
काश मैं सीरीज कंप्लीट ले देख लेता और मैं
इस एग्जाम को क्लियर कर पाता बिकॉज़ मेरी
सीरीज के बगैर आप एग्जाम क्लियर नहीं कर
पाओगे यह मेरा प्रॉमिस है क्योंकि एग्जाम
बनाने वाला भी मैं ही हूं पढ़ाने वाला भी
मैं ही हूं और आपका प्रक्टर भी मैं ही
रहूंगा तो सोच लीजिए कि अब तीनों चीज मैं
ही हूं तो अब मैं जिस तरीके से पढ़ाता हूं
तो एग्जाम का पैटर्न भी उसी तरीके से आता
है क्योंकि आपको पता है कि जब मैं छोटी
छोटी-छोटी चीजें पढ़ाता हूं। तो, यह हर एक
छोटी-छोटी चीजें और इतनी बारीकी एग्जाम
में बहुत मायने रखने वाली है। क्योंकि
आपने एक चीज मिस की और हो सकता है कि आप
पूरे-पूरे क्वेश्चंस को ही या पूरे-पूरे
ही पाथ को आप राइट पाथ से रॉन्ग पाथ पर
चले जाओ जिससे आप एग्जाम क्लियर ना कर
पाओ। और जैसे मैं बताता हूं कि यह तो मेरे
एग्जाम के बात रही मेरे एग्जाम की। बट
हम और बाकी एग्जाम की कंपैरिजन करें तो वह
भी आप दे सकते हो। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है।
ईजीपे टीसीएस एग्जाम तो यह पढ़ने के बाद
बिल्कुल छोटा सा सर्टिफिकेशन है जो आप
बहुत ही आसानी से कर लोगे। कुछ नहीं। जस्ट
ये कोर्स कंप्लीट होने के बाद बस आप क्या
करो? एक बार क्विक रीजन रिवीजन करो या
आपने अगर सही से क्लासेस अटेंड किए हैं आप
लोगों के पास नोट्स हैं सब कुछ है तो आपको
कुछ भी जरूरत नहीं है। बस जस्ट एक बार आप
उस नोट्स को गो थ्रू करना और डायरेक्टली
आप अटेंड कर सकते हो। तो इट्स ओके हम हां
टफ होगा डेफिनेटली एक रियल पेन टेस्टिंग
टाइप रेड टिमर एग्जाम टाइप हम रख सकते
हैं। तो आई एम प्लानिंग और अभी उस पे मैं
आपको सच बताऊं तो धीरे-धीरे काम करना
स्टार्ट कर रहा हूं मेरे फ्री टाइम में।
तो डोंट वरी
अच्छी बात है वो कर लीजिए कोई मना नहीं कर
रहा उसको भी कर सकते हो तो चलो हम क्लास
को स्टार्ट करते हैं नाउ
अ
आज की क्लास में हम सबसे पहले sh प्लस में
आरटीपी
वॉइ ट्रैफिक एनालिसिस से स्टार्ट करने
वाले हैं। सबसे पहले हम किससे स्टार्ट
करेंगे? शिप प्लस आरटीपी ऑडियो ट्रैफिक
एनालिसिस। जैसे कि आपने टाइटल देखा होगा
कि पहली बात तो यह वही पन टेस्टिंग का भाग
पांच कौन सा है पेन टेस्टिंग का पार्ट फोर
है भाग फोर है बात इंग्लिश हिंदी में बोले
तो और दूसरा क्या है कि जैसे कि आपने
टाइटल देखा होगा कि हम इससे शिप ट्रैफिक
से शिप प्लस आरटीपी ट्रैफिक से ऑडियो को
क्या करने वाले हैं? एक्सट्रैक्ट करने
वाले हैं। तो वही है आज का टॉपिक हमारा
क्या है कि शिप और शिप और आरटीपी ट्रैफिक
एनालिसिस से स्टार्टिंग उस उस ट्रैफिक को
एनालाइज करना और उसमें क्या करने वाले हैं
हम? पैकेट को एनालाइज करेंगे। एग्जजेक्टली
वैसे ही जैसे रियल वर्ल्ड में नेटवर्क
पैकेट को एनालाइज किया जाता है। कहां पर
एनालाइज किया जाता है? जैसे चाहे कोई भी
शॉक टीम हो उसके अंदर भी इन पैकेट्स को
एनालाइज किया जाता है। ड्यूरिंग पेंट
टेस्ट, ड्यूरिंग फॉरेंसिक इन सब जगह पर इन
पैकेट्स को क्या किया जाता है? एनालाइज
किया जाता है। नाउ अभी हम बात करते हैं कि
जो वॉइप ट्रैफिक होती है उसमें काफी सारे
प्रोटोकॉल्स होते हैं। लेकिन जो आज की
क्लास है, वह स्पेसिफिकली फोकस किस पे कर
रही है? शिप और आरटीपी। हमने आज की क्लास
में स्पेसिफिकली फोकस किया है शिप और
आरटीपी। इसका रीजन सिंपल है क्योंकि मैं
पहले दिन से आपको पढ़ा चुका हूं। आपको
बताया है कि शिप किस लिए यूज किया जाता
है? कॉल को सेटअप करने के लिए और
सिग्नलिंग कंट्रोल करने के लिए। और आरटीपी
का भी पता है कि आरटीपी में क्या होता है
कि आरटीपी में आपकी जो वॉइस है या जो
एक्चुअल आपका जो स्ट्रीम पैकेट है वो
ट्रैवल करते हैं। और मैं आपको एक चीज बता
देता हूं कि अगर आपने शिप और आरटीपी को
अच्छे से समझ लिया या इसकी जो नॉलेज गेन
आपने अच्छे से कर ली तो इसका मतलब यह है
कि आपका जो वप है वो 80 टू 90% क्लियर हो
गया। 80 टू 90% वप आपको समझ में आ गया।
अभी हम क्या करने वाले हैं? हम एग्जांपल
इस पूरी क्लास में हम एग्जांपल लेने वाले
हैं। और जो एग्जांपल हम लेंगे वो क्या है?
टू कॉलर कन्वर्जेशन मतलब दो लोगों की
बातचीत जिसमें सिर्फ दो यूज़र्स होंगे।
यूजर ए यूजर बी और उन्हीं के बीच का हमने
क्या किया है?
जो पीकैप फाइल है उन्हीं के बीच बीच से जो
ट्रैफिक है उसको हमने कैप्चर किया हुआ है।
एक फाइल में सेव किया हुआ है। ऑलरेडी वो
फाइल हम यूज़ कर भी चुके हैं। बट आज हम उस
पूरी फाइल को समझ लेंगे काफी डिटेल्स में।
उसमें हम क्या देखने वाले हैं? हम देखने
वाले हैं कि कॉल कैसे स्टार्ट होती है,
पैकेज्स कैसे फ्लो करते हैं और दो चीजें
आपको पता है कि कौन सा ट्रैफिक सिग्नलिंग
है या कौन सा ट्रैफिक शिफ्ट ट्रैफिक है या
शिप फ्लो करता है और कौन सा ट्रैफिक आपका
एक्चुअल वॉइस डाटा कैरी कर रहा है या हम
बोले कि कौन सा कौन सा ट्रैफिक आपका
आरटीपी ट्रैफिक है। ये चीज आपको बिल्कुल
क्लियर है क्योंकि ये दोनों चीज मैं आपको
प्रीवियस की जो क्लास है क्लास वन टू थ्री
इनमें मैं आपको पढ़ा चुका हूं वब से
रिलेटेड। लेकिन हम बात करते हैं कि जब भी
हम वप ट्रैफिक एनालिसिस को शुरू करते हैं
या जब भी हम वप एनालिसिस व ट्रैफिक
एनालिसिस को स्टार्ट करने की करना चाहते
हैं तो उसमें एक सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप
होता है जिसके बारे में आपको पता भी होना
चाहिए और मैं आपको बता भी देता हूं और
आपको पता है ऑलरेडी मैं इसके बारे में
डिस्कस कर चुका हूं। दैट इज कॉल्ड ट्रैफिक
क्लासिफिकेशन। ट्रैफिक क्लासिफिकेशन में
क्या होता है कि नेटवर्क में कौन-कौन से
टाइप के व ट्रैफिक आ सकते हैं? जो आपका
नेटवर्क है उसमें कौन-कौन से टाइप के वॉइप
ट्रैफिक आते हैं वह सारी चीजें क्या आपके
किसके अंदर है ट्रैफिक क्लासिफिकेशंस में
प्रेजेंट रहते हैं। तो क्योंकि अगर आपको
ट्रैफिक क्लासिफिकेशंस के बारे में नॉलेज
नहीं है तो क्या होगा कि जब भी आप वायरस
में ट्रैफिक एनालिसिस करोगे तो आपको सब
कुछ उलझ पुलज लगेगा या आप कंफ्यूज हो
जाओगे। आपको चीजें समझ में नहीं आएगी। दैट
इज व्हाई हम देखने वाले हैं टाइप्स ऑफ
ट्रैफिक। यह सबको पता है कि शिप और आरटीपी
ही हमारा टॉपिक है। सबसे पहले हम बात
करेंगे कि फर्स्ट टाइप कौन सा होता है
आपका? शिप प्लस आरटीपी जो टोटली
अनइंकिप्टेड होता है। उसके बाद होता है
आपका शिप ओवर टीएलएस प्लस आरटीपी। दूसरा
टाइप जिसमें क्या होता है? जो शिप है आपका
जो आपका सिग्नलिंग कंट्रोल है वो क्या
होता है? इंक्रिप्टेड होता है और जो आपका
आरटीपी है वो इंक्रिप्टेड नहीं होता। वहीं
पर अगर हम बात करें थर्ड टाइप का थर्ड
टाइप होता है आपका शिप प्लस में एसआरटीपी
शिप मतलब आपका जो कंट्रोलिंग
जो आपका
बोले सिग्नलिंग कंट्रोल है वो क्या होता
है इंक्रिप्टेड नहीं होता लेकिन जो आपका
वॉइस डेटा है वो इंक्रिप्टेड होता है और
सबसे लास्ट और फोर्थ पॉइंट जो होता है
आपका कि दोनों के दोनों इंक्रिप्टेड होते
हैं जो आपका शिप है आपका जो सिग्नलिंग
प्रोटोकॉल्स है जो सिग्नलिंग कंट्रोल है
वो भी आपका क्या होता है इंक्रिप्टेड होता
है और जो एसआरटीपी जो आरटीपी है जो आपका
एक्चुअल जिसमें जिसके अंदर आपकी जो वॉइस
ट्रेवल करती है जिसमें आपकी जो स्ट्रीम
ट्रेवल करती है वॉइस स्ट्रीम ट्रेवल करती
है वो क्या होता है इंक्रिप्टेड दोनों ही
इंक्रिप्टेड होते इट इज अ मोस्ट मोर
सिक्यर्ड तो नाउ हमारा जो फोकस है वो फोकस
हमारा शिप प्लस में आरटीपी मतलब किसके ऊपर
हमारा फोकस है शिप प्लस आरटीपी हमारा जो
हमारा टॉपिक है अनइंकिप्टेड ये हमारा
टॉपिक है ओके तो नाउ तो बिफोर एनालाइजिंग
ए व कन्वर्जेशन इट इजेंट टू अंडरस्टैंड
हाउ द डेटा फ्लो इज स्ट्रक्चर। तो मैं
आपको समझाता हूं। किसी भी वॉल को डीपली
एनालाइज करने से पहले हमारे लिए सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज क्या है? कि एक बिग पिक्चर
को समझना। हमारे लिए सबसेेंट क्या है? एक
बड़ी पिक्चर को समझना। वो कैसे? उसके लिए
हमें क्या करना होगा? हमें देखना है कि
कोल के अंदर कौन-कौन से कंपोनेंट कैसे
इंटरकनेक्टेड हैं। कोल के अंदर कौन-कौन से
कंपोनेंट हैं और वो आपस में कैसे
इंटरकनेक्टेड है। मतलब ये जो बड़ी
पिक्चर्स है जब हमें इसके बारे में पता चल
जाएगा उसके बाद में हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
ट्रैफिक को काफी आसानी से एनालाइज कर
पाएंगे। तो अभी मैं आपको क्या करता हूं?
एक ब्लॉक डायग्राम से समझाता हूं। फॉर
एग्जांपल्स हम बोल रहे हैं कि जब भी यूजर
ए है या जब भी अब कॉलर ए है बात करता है
बात करता है तो क्या होता है जो वीडियो है
जो ऑडियो है वो क्या होती है डायरेक्टली
कभी भी कॉलर बी के पास ट्रैवल नहीं करती
फ्लो नहीं करती बीच में सर्वर का यूज किया
जाता है यह चीज आपको बिल्कुल क्लियर है
आपको यह चीज अच्छे से पता है यानी कि हम
कह सकते हैं कि एक स्टैंडर्ड टू कॉलर व
कॉल क्रिएट फोर टोटल मीडिया स्ट्रीम्स
कहने का मतलब क्या है कि एक सिंपल सिंपल
जो कॉल है दो लोगों के बीच की जो बातचीत
है वो टोटल चार इंडिपेंडेंट आरटीपी
स्ट्रीम को जनरेट करती है। तो कहने का
मतलब कि दो लोग बात कर रहे होते हैं लेकिन
नेटवर्क लेवल पर टोटल चार स्ट्रीम्स चल
रही होती है। कैसे? जैसे स्ट्रीम वन,
स्ट्रीम टू, स्ट्रीम थ्री एंड स्ट्रीम
फोर। ओके? तो दिस दी स्ट्रीम रिप्रेजेंट द
कंप्लीट बायडायरेक्शनल ऑडियो एक्सचेंज
बिटवीन बोथ यूज़र्स। मतलब वी कैन से दैट
क्या है कि जब दो यूज़र्स आपस में बात
करेंगे तो क्या होता है कि उनके बीच में
टोटल चार स्ट्रीम कन्वर्ट होती है। क्लास
को छोड़ के मत जाइए। बिकॉज़ आपको लग आपको
लगता है कि हमने ये चीज पढ़ी हुई है। हमें
आईडिया है कि सर रिपीट कर रहे हैं। मैं
रिपीट नहीं कर रहा क्योंकि मैं पीछे की
क्लास में जो कुछ पढ़ाया था उसको
इंटरकनेक्ट कर रहा हूं। क्योंकि उसके बाद
हमें कैरी फॉरवर्ड करना है। उस चीज में
आगे बढ़ना है। इसलिए मेरा क्या है कि
थोड़ा सा पैटर्न ये होता है कि प्रीवियस
क्लास का और प्रेजेंट क्लास को थोड़ा सा
इंटरकनेक्ट करना ताकि प्रीवियस क्लास में
जो कुछ पढ़ा था और अब जो हम पढ़ने वाले
हैं वो आपको क्या पता चल जाए। आपको क्लियर
हो जाए कि चल क्या रहा है। क्योंकि हमारे
पास क्या है कि YouTube स्ट्रीम है।
YouTube स्ट्रीम में क्या है कि हम
डायरेक्टली कम्युनिकेट नहीं कर सकते। वहीं
पर अगर हम Google मीट पर होते तो
कम्युनिकेट कर पाते और आप में से कोई भी
एक स्टूडेंट उसको एक्सप्लेन करता। इसलिए
क्या होता है कि बाकी स्टूडेंट्स को वो
चीजें पता चल जाती है कि पहले क्लास में
क्या हुआ था और आज की क्लास में क्या हो
रहा है। ओके तो नाउ
अभी व्हाई फोर स्ट्रीम्स ऑफ ओनली टू कॉलर
मतलब क्या है कि अब सवाल यह है कि ये जो
चार स्ट्रीम मॉडल है ये जो क्या है कि दो
लोग बातचीत कर रहे हैं और ये चार स्ट्रीम
क्यों ऐसा क्यों? इनके तीन रीजन है। पहली
बात कि जो स्टैंडर्ड है कि जो व ऑडियो है
कभी भी डायरेक्टली कॉलर्स के साथ फ्लो
नहीं करेगी, इंटैक्ट नहीं करेगी। हमेशा
क्या करेगी? वह बीच में इन बिटवीन व सर्वर
का यूज करेगी या किसी भी पीबीएस का यूज़
करेगी। पीबीx सर्वर का यूज़ करने वाली है।
ये दो कारण हो गए। थर्ड वन क्या है कि जो
हर एक डायरेक्शन होती है आरटीपी की जो हर
एक डायरेक्शन है स्ट्रीम वन है चाहे आपका
स्ट्रीम टू है चाहे आपका स्ट्रीम थ्री है।
ये रहा कौन सा आपका स्ट्रीम वन, स्ट्रीम
टू, स्ट्रीम थ्री और स्ट्रीम फोर। जो
डायरेक्शन आप एरो डायरेक्शन देखोगे ये
सारी की सारी चीजें क्या है? आपकी
इंडिपेंडेंट ट्रीट की जाती है। दैट इज
व्हाई कि यहां पर क्या किया जा रहा है कि
दो लोग बातचीत करते हैं और चार स्ट्रीम
जनरेट होती है। फिर भी अब सवाल ये आता है
कि यह जो चार स्ट्रीम मॉडल है इतना
इंपॉर्टेंट क्यों है? क्योंकि जब हम बात
करते हैं एसआरटीपी की उस केस में यह जो
फोर स्ट्रीम मॉडल है काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है
क्योंकि चलिए देखते हैं कैसेेंस ऑफ दिस
मॉडल इन एसआरटीपी इंक्रिप्शन जब भी हम
क्या करेंगे आने वाली क्लासेस में
एसआरटीपी इंक्रिप्शन को देखेंगे तब आपको
पता चल जाएगा कि यह चार स्ट्रीम मॉडल
इतनाेंट क्यों है इन एसआरटीपी ईच मीडिया
स्ट्रीम इज इंक्रिप्टेड इंडिपेंडेंटली
एसआरटी में क्या क्या होता है कि
जो हर एक मीडिया स्ट्रीम है उसको
इंडिपेंडेंटली इंक्रिप्ट किया जाता है। नो
सिंगल ग्लोबल की इज़ यूज़्ड। ईच आरटीपी
डायरेक्शन मे हैव ए डिफरेंट इंक्रिप्शन की
ए डिफरेंट एसएसआरसी आइडेंटिफायर ए डिफरेंट
सीक्वेंस नंबर रेंज ए सेपरेट डिक्रिप्शन
रिक्वायरमेंट मींस एनालिस्ट मस्ट ट्रीट ईच
स्ट्रीम सेपरेटली ड्यूरिंग इंक्रिप्शन
फॉरेंसिक एंड एनालिसिस। चलो मैं एक्सप्लेन
करता हूं कि जब भी हम क्या करने वाले हैं
जो एसआरटीपी इंक्रिप्शन है उसको क्या
करेंगे? देखेंगे या उसके साथ हम डील
करेंगे तो वहां पर आप क्या एक एक चीज क्या
देखोगे कि एसआरटीपी क्या कर सकता है हर एक
डायरेक्शन के लिए अलग की यूज़ कर सकता है
इस डायरेक्शन के लिए भी अलग की यूज़ कर
सकता है इस डायरेक्शन के लिए भी अलग की
यूज़ कर सकता है स्ट्रीम थ्री के लिए भी
अलग की यूज़ कर सकता है और स्ट्रीम फोर के
लिए भी अलग की यूज़ कर सकता है मतलब कि अगर
आप क्या करने वाले हो जब एसआरटीपी के अंदर
डीप एनालिसिस करोगे तो वहां पर आपको एक
चीज देखने को मिलेगी कि
कि हर डायरेक्शन ऑपरेशन वाइज इंडिपेंडेंट
है। जो भी डायरेक्शन है वह ऑपरेशन वाइज
आपको लगेगा क्या कि इंडिपेंडेंट है। जब भी
तुम क्या करोगे कि जो एसआरटी ट्रैफिक को
कैप्चर करोगे तो वहां पर एक यही नोटिस
करोगे कि हर स्ट्रीम का अपना अलग
इंक्रिप्शन की है। ये चीज आप 100% नोटिस
करने वाले हो कि हर एक स्ट्रीम की अपनी
अलग की है। लाइक फॉर एग्जांपल्स हम बात
करें स्ट्रीम वन ए2 सर्वर की वन स्ट्रीम
टू सर्वर टू बी की टू स्ट्रीम थ्री बी टू
सर्वर की थ्री स्ट्रीम फोर सर्वर टू ए फिर
से की फोर मतलब हम कह सकते हैं कि कोई भी
एक की पूरी कॉल को डिक्रिप्ट नहीं कर
सकती। तुम्हें क्या करना पड़ेगा? हर
स्ट्रीम के लिए अलग-अलग की चाहिए। अगर
स्ट्रीम वन को डिक्रिप्ट करना है तो अलग
की चाहिए। स्ट्रीम ट्रिक को डिक्रिप्ट
करना है तो अलग की चाहिए। स्ट्रीम थ्री को
डिक्रिप्ट करना है तो उसके लिए अलग की
चाहिए। मतलब हर एक स्ट्रीम के लिए आपको एक
अलग की चाहिए। इसीलिए जब भी क्या होता है
जब भी हम क्या करते हैं या कोई भी
फॉरेंसिक एनालिसिस करता है या डिक्रिप्शन
करता है या पैकेट एनालिसिस करता है तो हर
एक स्ट्रीम को अलग-अलग तरीके से हैंडल
करता है और क्योंकि अगर आप क्या कर पा रहे
हो कि किसी भी एक स्ट्रीम को डिक्रिप्ट कर
पाए या आप क्या आपने क्या किया कि किसी भी
एक स्ट्रीम को डिक्रिप्ट कर लिया तो इसका
मतलब बिल्कुल यह नहीं है कि बाकी भी जो
स्ट्रीम स्ट्रीम है वो डिक्रिप्ट हो
जाएंगी। यह बिल्कुल भी इसका मतलब नहीं है।
अगर आपने स्ट्रीम वन को डिक्रिप्ट कर लिया
तो स्ट्रीम टू, स्ट्रीम थ्री, स्ट्रीम फोर
के लिए अलग की चाहिए ना कि उस सेम की से
आप क्या इनको डिक्रिप्ट कर पाओगे। वी कैन
से दैट कि हर डायरेक्शन इंडिपेंडेंट है।
हर डायरेक्शन का अलग काम है। अलग पैकेट्स
है और अलग की का यूज किया जाता है। ओके?
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है? यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है?
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है गाइज?
चलिए नेक्स्ट अभी हम क्या करते हैं? इसका
प्रैक्टिकली देखते हैं। प्रैक्टिकली कैसे
देखने वाले हैं? चलिए हम एक काम करते हैं।
कैसे देखेंगे? चलो नाउ वी गो टू आवर से
पार्ट एपी। नाउ गो टू नॉर्मल कॉल टू
पार्टीज और इसको हम इसको किसके साथ ओपन
करने वाले हैं? वसार के साथ ओपन करने वाले
हैं। तो, यह चीज़ आपको आती है, यह चीज़ आपको
पता है। तो, इसमें कुछ चीजें हैं जो आपको
करनी है। तो, हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
टेलीफ़ोनिक के अंदर जाएंगे। टेलीफ़ोनिक के
अंदर हम क्या करने वाले हैं? शिफ्ट फ्लो
के अंदर जाएंगे। दीज़ ऑल आर द शिफ्ट फ्लो
कंट्रोल O और आपको क्या देखना है? फ्लो
सीक्वेंस। तो, आपको पता है यह चीज़ आपको
पता है। रजिस्टर 401 यहां पर देखो रजिस्टर
401 अन ऑथराइज़्ड फिर से रजिस्टर 200 ओके।
मतलब ये क्या आपका जो 192.168.20.132
जो कॉलर ए है उसने क्या किया सर्वर के साथ
रजिस्टर कर लिया सक्सेसफुली। नाउ उसी
प्रकार से 192.168
20.1 जो कॉलर टू है उसने भी क्या कर लिया?
रजिस्टर कर लिया किसके साथ? सर्वर के साथ
सक्सेसफुली। तो इसका जो यूजर आईडी है 11 1
इसका यूजर आईडी है 222। यह कैसे पता चला
मुझे? क्योंकि ये हम ऑलरेडी एनालाइज कर
चुके हैं। इसमें कुछ भी अलग चीज नहीं है।
उसके बाद अब बातचीत स्टार्ट होती है यहां
से। ये रहा कि अब स्टार्ट होती है कैसे?
कि जो कॉलर ए है जो आई जो आपका यूजर ए है
यूजर ए ने क्या किया? कॉल किया। किसने कॉल
किया? किसके पास? यूजर बी के पास।
192.16820.1
बट वो कॉल किसको कर रहा है? सर्वर को। चलो
इसका पैकेट एनालिसिस करते हैं कैसे? ठीक
है? तो यूजर ए ने क्या किया? एक कॉल की
किसके पास? यूजर बी के पास। और वह किसके
थ्रू जाएगी? सर्वर के थ्रू जाएगी। ये चीज
आपको बताते हैं। क्योंकि इंटरमीडिएट में
मिडिलमैन का काम कौन कर रहा है आपका?
सर्वर। और जो पहली रिक्वेस्ट कौन सी जाती
है आपको पता है? जब हमने पढ़ाया था अब
आपको मैंने शिप हैंडशिप के बारे में बताया
था। तो सबसे पहला कौन सा मैसेज था? इनवाइट
मैसेज। सबसे पहला मैसेज कौन सा था आपका?
इनवाइट मैसेज। और इनवाइट एसडीपी मैसेज है।
एसडीपी क्या है? आपका एक सब प्रोटोकॉल है
शिप का। क्योंकि जब भी क्या होता है कि जब
भी कोई एक यूजर एजेंट किसी दूसरे यूजर
एजेंट के साथ बातचीत करना चाहता है या
उसको कॉल करना चाहता है उस केस में क्या
होता है कि वो अपने सेशन को डिस्क्राइब
करते हैं। अपना प्रॉपर्ली हर चीज उसमें
डिस्क्राइब करते हैं। जैसे कि कॉल का ओनर
कौन होगा? मीडिया डिस्क्रिप्शन लाइक कि
कौन सी इनकोडिंग या डिकोडिंग प्रोटोकॉल्स
को हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं। क्या मेरा आईपी
एड्रेस रहेगा? किस पोर्ट पे हम बातचीत
करने वाले हैं। हर एक चीज को हम क्या वो
चीजें डिफाइन रहती है। तो लेट्स सी कि
इसको हम एनालाइज करते हैं। और एक काम करते
हैं इसको। ये रहा
नाउ वी विल इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं। नाउ
गो टू दिस।
यह रहा मैसेज और इसको हम स्टॉप कर दे यहां
पर। जब इस पे हमने क्लिक कर लिया। यह रहा
जब इस पे क्लिक किया तो यहां पर स्लप है।
यह रहा शिप एसडीपी पैट पैकेट और यहां पर
अगर आप देखोगे तो यह रहा यूजर डाटा ग्राम
प्रोटोकॉल यूडीपी सोर्स पोर्ट क्या है?
56330 डेस्टिनेशन पोर्ट है 5060 ओके इट्स
ओके कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। यह शिप है। कौन
सा मैसेज है? इनवाइट मैसेज है आपके।
रिक्वेस्ट लाइन में क्या है आपका? यह रहा।
रिक्वेस्ट लाइन में क्या है आपका? इनवाइट
मैसेज है शिफ्ट 2222@
192.168.2130
मतलब क्या है कि इनवाइट मेथड का यूज किया
गया है। रिक्वेस्ट यूआर में क्या है कि
मुझे यह सर्वर को बोल रहा है कि प्लीज
कनेक्ट मी टू यूजर 222 मतलब यूजर बी के
साथ मुझे कनेक्ट करना है इस आईडी के साथ
क्योंकि वहां पर यूजर बी कॉलर बी यह कोई
नाम नहीं है। उसका एक नंबर है। एक आईडी
है। उस आईडी को इसने यहां पर मेंशन किया
है और इसने किसको बोला? सर्वर को। सर्वर
को क्यों बोला? क्योंकि सर्वर को पता है।
ओके? उसके बाद अगर हम मैसेज हेडर में
देखते हैं तो वाया हेडर है। वाया हेडर में
आपको पता है क्या-क्या है? वाया हेडर में
आपको पता है क्या-क्या है आपका? यूडीपी
प्रोटोकॉल का यूज़ किया गया है। उसके बाद
सेंट बाय एड्रेस। किसने इसको सेंड किया
है? यह रहा आईपी एड्रेस। कौन से पोर्सेस
को भेजा गया है? यह आरप मतलब यहां पर क्या
है? नेट हैंडलिंग इनेबल्ड है। उसके बाद यह
इसका ब्रांच एक यूनिक ट्रांजक्शन आईडी है।
प्रीवियस क्लास में इसको देख चुके हैं।
इसमें कुछ भी अलग नहीं है। नेक्स्ट मैक्स
फॉरवर्ड क्या है? 70 ये आपके टीटीएल का
काम करता है। आपको पता है जब भी आप पिन
करते हो तो वहां पे एक टीटीएल वैल्यू आती
है। सेम उसी प्रकार से यहां पे भी एक
टीटीएल वैल्यू है। देन उसके बाद फ्रॉम
एड्रेस देखो। फ्रॉम एड्रेस में देखोगे तो
किसका एड्रेस है? फ्रॉम किससे? फ्रॉम मतलब
फ्रॉम मतलब कॉलर की आइडेंटिटी। किसने कॉल
की है? कॉलर कौन है? 11 1 और किसको कॉल
किया उसने? सर्वर को। उसके टैग आईडी क्या
है? यूनिक आईडी। यह है इसकी टैग आईडी। D3
F6 सीf डी। उसके बाद किसको कॉल किया है?
शिप ये रहा शिप एड्रेस। किसको? 222 और साथ
में सर्वर का IPपी एड्रेस। मतलब यह बोल
रहा है कि मैं
कौन यूजर ए मतलब 1 1 यह यूजर हूं। मैं कॉल
इनिशिएट कर रहा हूं। और किसको कॉल जा रहा
है यह? यूजर टू को या यूजर बी को जिसकी
आईडी क्या है? 222 मतलब यहां पर किसको कॉल
किया जा रहा है? यूजर बी को कॉल किया जा
रहा है सर्वर के थ्रू। उसकी टैग आईडी नहीं
है क्योंकि वो अभी तक उसने कोई भी कॉल
एक्सेप्ट नहीं किया है। उसके बाद कांटेक्ट
हेडर आपको पता है क्यों होता है? कांटेक्ट
हेडर? कांटेक्ट हेडर में क्या है कि अगर
सामने वाले पार्टी जो एजेंट है कॉल रिसीव
कर लेता है तो मुझे अगर आपको कम्युनिकेट
करना है रिस्पांस देना है तो आप जो यहां
डिटेल मैंने मेंशन की है जो डिटेल्स मैंने
यहां पर मेंशन की है एक मिनट गाइस
गाइस वन मिनट थोड़ा सा थोड़ा सा थोड़ा सा इशू
हो गया था फ्रॉम माय साइड नाउ इट्स ओके
फाइन आई एम कमिंग बैक टू माय टॉपिक चलिए
इनकमिंग कहां पर था मैं हम कहां पर थे ओके
हम थे कांटेक्ट हेडर पे तो कांटेक्ट हेडर
में क्या है कि अगर किसी को रिस्पांस करना
है किसको इस यूजर को तो मुझे यहां पर
कांटेक्ट करना है इन डिटेल्स पर यह उसकी
आईडी है यह उसका आईपी एड्रेस है यह उसका
पोर्ट है और यह उसका पैरामीटर्स है यह
उसकी कॉल आईडी है सबको पता है कॉल आईडी
किस लिए यूज़ की जाती है उसके बाद क्या है
की कॉल आईडी है उसके बाद कमांड सीक्वेंस
आपको पता है किस लिए यूज़ किया जाता है।
उसके बाद यहां पर मेथड कौन-कौन से अलाउड
हैं? सपोर्टेड प्रोटोकॉल्स कौन-कौन से
हैं? सेशन एक्सपायरेशन टाइम दिया हुआ है।
कितनी देर का यह? 30 मिनट के लिए। 1800
सेकंड 30 मिनट मिनिमम 90 सेकंड यूजर एजेंट
कौन सा यूज़ किया जाए? माइक्रोसिफ
एप्लीकेशन टाइप एसडीपी कंटेंट। अब क्या
कंटेंट है। कंटेंट लेंथ 4 1 यहां कंटेंट
लेंथ में क्या दिया गया है? 4 1 इसका मतलब
क्या है? कि यहां इसके अंदर मैसेज बॉडी है
और उसकी लेंथ क्या है? जो मैसेज बॉडी है
उसकी लेंथ है 411। मतलब इससे पता चल रहा
है कि सर्वर को कि उसका जो मैसेज है वो
कहां पर एंड होगा? तो मैसेज बॉडी में क्या
आपका? मैसेज बॉडी में आपका एसडीपी। मैसेज
बॉडी में क्या है आपका? एसडीपी। सेशन
डिस्क्रिप्शन प्रोटोकॉल। सेशन
डिस्क्रिप्शन प्रोटोकॉल क्या होता है कि
बेसिकली एक टेक्स्ट डॉक्यूमेंट होता है।
जो सेशन डिस्क्रिप्शन एसडीपी क्या होता है
आपका? यह जो एसडीपी है यह क्या होता है
आपका एक टेक्स्ट डॉक्यूमेंट जिसके अंदर
क्या है जिसके अंदर यह चीज डिफाइन की जाती
है कि मैं ऑडियो कैसे भेजूंगा कौन से कोडक
को यूज करूंगा मेरा आईपी क्या है मेरा
आरटीपी पोर्ट क्या होगा मैं ऑडियो रिसीव
भी कर सकता हूं या नहीं कर सकता या मैं
ऑडियो को सिर्फ सेंड कर सकता हूं या सिर्फ
रिसीव कर सकता हूं या डीटीएमएफ टोंस मेरी
कैसे सेंड करूंगा मैं या मैक्सिमम बैंडविथ
कितनी यूज करने वाला हूं यह सारी डिटेल्स
किसके अंदर डिफाइन की जाती जाती है इसके
अंदर। किसके अंदर? एसडीपी के अंदर।
बेसिकली यहां पर क्या हो रहा है कि जो
यूजर ए है वह बोल रहा है कि आई एम आईपी
192.168.20.132
माय ऑडियो सोन सो ये रहा। मैं यह IPपी
एड्रेस हूं। मेरी ऑडियो 4000 है। मैं
ऑडियो पोर्ट यूज़ कर रहा हूं। 4000 है।
कौन-कौन से आरटीपी प्रोटोकॉल सपोर्ट करता
हूं। और यह मैं कोडक्स सपोर्ट करता हूं।
प्लीज मेरे को सेंड कीजिए। तो यहां पर आप
देखोगे तो यहां पर ये ये ओनर ये ओनर की
डिटेल है। यहां पर कौन कौन है ओनर
192.168.20132
उसके बाद यह कुछ नहीं है। इस पे ज्यादा
ध्यान नहीं है। बैंडविथ इनेशन है। बैंडविथ
इनेशन में क्या आपका बैंडविथ इनेशन है कि
कितनी बैंडविड्थ यूज़ करने वाली है कॉल।
मतलब कितनी सपोर्ट करती है? 84 मतलब 84
KBs
यूज़ करने वाली है यह कॉल। मतलब इससे कोई
भी प्रॉब्लम नहीं होनी है। टाइम
डिस्क्रिप्शन में क्या दिया गया है कि
यहां पर कोई भी स्टार्ट टाइम और एंड टाइम
नहीं डिसाइड किया। कोई भी फिक्स नहीं है
कि कि जो इस टाइम पे स्टार्ट होगी यह इतने
टाइम के लिए इस टाइम पे एंड होगी। सेशन
एट्रिब्यूट मतलब जो नेट एट्रिब्यूट है
किसके लिए? नेट डिटेक्शन के लिए। नेट क्या
होता है आपका? नेट होता है नेटवर्क एड्रेस
ट्रांसलेशन। मतलब यहां पर क्या है कि नेट
इनेबल नहीं है। मतलब बाहर कोई कॉल नहीं हो
रहा। इंटरनल ही कॉल किया जा रहा है। अलग
से कोई नेट का यूज़ नहीं किया जा रहा।
नेटवर्क एड्रेस ट्रांसलेट यह आपका मीडिया
डिस्क्रिप्शन है। यह आपका मीडिया डिस्क
मीडिया टाइप ऑडियो मीडिया पोर्ट कौन सा
4000 कौन सा प्रोटोकॉल्स है? कौन-कौन से
मीडिया फॉर्मेट है? उसके बाद यह सारी
डिटेल्स मतलब इस सारी चीज को आपको जानने
की बिल्कुल भी जरूरत नहीं है। क्योंकि जब
भी कोई कॉल परफॉर्म की जाती है तो बहुत
सारे पैराटर्स, बहुत सारे प्रोटोकॉल्स,
बहुत सारी चीजें होती हैं जो डिफाइन की
जाती है पहले से ही कि जब हम हमारे जो
बातचीत होगी जब हमारा कम्युनिकेशन होगा।
तो ये मेरे मीडिया पैराटर्स हैं। ये
मीडिया की इंफॉर्मेशन है। मेरे ये सारे
एट्रिब्यूट्स हैं। मैं ये चीजें डिफाइन
करता हूं। इसके अकॉर्डिंग ही हमारी बातचीत
होगी। तो सेम अपोजिट साइड से भी यही होता
है। अपोजिट मतलब सेकंड यूजर एजेंट। तो
इसमें सारी चीजें आप खुद से भी पढ़ सकते
हो। आप जो एनालाइज करोगे और आई एम सॉरी
फॉर दैट कि मैं आपको यह फाइल प्रोवाइड
करना भूल गया था। डोंट वरी आपको आज सेशन
के बाद मैं बोल दूंगा नितेश सर को कि जो
हमारा WhatsApp का चैनल है जो WhatsApp
चैनल है जो डिपॉनिक्स का चैनल है उसके
अंदर यह मीडिया स्ट्रीम फाइल क्या कर दी
जाएंगी? शेयर कर दी जाएंगी। प्लीज वहां से
आप क्या करना कर लेना इनको डाउनलोड करके
अपने प्रैक्टिकल एनालिसिस परफॉर्म कर सकते
हो इट्स ओके तो इसके लिए मुझे माफी देना
क्योंकि मैं भूल गया था इस चीज को मैं
दिमाग से उतर गई थी मैं मतलब भूल गया था
ओके तो ये चीज नेक्स्ट हम क्या करते हैं
ये रहा उसके बाद क्या हुआ कि 401 अन
ऑथराइज्ड वही है सर्वर को पहला मैसेज को
क्या करना है 401 भेजना ही है 401 में
क्या हुआ ये रहा 401 यहां से ध्यान देखो
ये देखो देखोगे 401 अन ऑथराइज्ड स्टेटस
कोड 401 है। मैसेज हेडर यह सेम वही चीजें
हैं। ब्रांच आईडी सेम मिलेगी। टैग आईडी
कॉल आईडी सेम मिलने वाली है। इट्स ओके।
नेक्स्ट 401 के बाद क्या हुआ? फिर से
सर्वर ने क्या किया? इसने
यूजर ने इसको एकनॉलेजमेंट दी। ओके। बोला
ओके आपने 401 भेजा है। चलो कोई बात नहीं
है। मैं एक काम करता हूं। अभी इसको क्या
करता हूं? 401 में क्या किया? उसने चैलेंज
दिया है। ध्यान से देखोगे। 401 का पैकेट
यह रहा। यहां पर ऑथेंटिकेशन डाइजेस्ट
ऑथेंटिकेशन
किया। यहां पर क्या क्या भेजा इन्होंने?
डाइजेस्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन भेजा यहां पर।
डाइजेस्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन तो उसके बाद
ऑथेंटिकेशन चैलेंज है। एकनॉलेजमेंट किया।
उसके बाद फिर से इनवाइट मैसेज भेजा। अब की
बार इन्होंने क्या किया? इनवाइट मेथड ये
सारी चीजें हैं। यहां पर हम देखेंगे
एक्स्ट्रा क्या चीज ऐड हुई? ऑथराइजेशन
हेडर ये रहा। मतलब यहां पर ऑथेंटिकेशन
चैलेंज को सॉल्व किया है। और यह उसकी
वैल्यू होगी। ये रहा md5 है। वैल्यू ये
रही। और सेम जैसे कि मैंने प्रीवियस क्लास
में बताया था कि यह जो डाइजेस्ट
ऑथेंटिकेशन कैसे परफॉर्म किया जाता है यह
आप स्लाइड में देख चुके हो तो वो सेम
तरीके से इसमें भी डाइजेस्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन
परफॉर्म किया जाता है। तो ये उसकी एमडी5
वैल्यू ये नस वैल्यू ओपेक वैल्यू q वैल्यू
ये सारी चीजें आपको पता चल गया होगा। देन
उसके बाद हुआ क्या? उसके बाद फिर सर्वर ने
सेम टाइम रिस्पांस क्या दिया? ओके 100
ट्राइंग आपको मैंने बताया था कि जब सब
इनवाइट मैसेज जाता है इनवाइट के बाद 401
अनथराइज़ आया। इसने एकनॉलेजमेंट भेज दिया।
यह प्रैक्टिकली है यहां पर। वहां पे कुछ
और तरीके से मैंने आपको एक्सप्लेन किया
था। लेकिन फिर से इनवाइट मेथड है। यहां पर
ऑथेंटिकेशन चैलेंज इंस्टॉल करते हुए उसके
बाद 100 ट्राइंग जाता है। मतलब कि मैं
ट्राई कर रहा हूं। सेशन स्टार्ट नहीं है।
उसके बाद 180 रिंगिंग मतलब रिंग स्टार्ट
होने। आपको एक आवाज आती है टर करके जो भी
व्हाटएवर आवाज होती है वो आपको सुनाई
देगी। उसके बाद क्या सेम टाइम जो सर्वर था
सर्वर ने क्या किया? इसको इनवाइट एसडीपी
पैकेट किसको भेजा? किसको भेजा? यह आपके
कॉलर टू को। आप किसको भेजा? कॉलर टू को।
ध्यान से देखोगे तो यह कॉलर टू आपका यहां
पर अभी देखते हैं। अभी यह आपका कॉलर टू
है। तो कॉलर टू पे हम जाते हैं। यह आपका
कॉलर टू है। इसने भेजा इनवाइट रिक्वेस्ट
लाइन देगा। इनवाइट 22 टू 2 किसके पास?
किससे भेज इसने? शिप 222 51 और ये रहा।
ओके। ये सारा मैसेज सेम है। इसमें कुछ भी
अलग नहीं है। फ्रॉम बॉब से इसमें जो लिखा
हुआ है नाम है शिप 111 से। मतलब किससे आई
है और किसको जा रही है। यहां पर अब की बार
देखोगे आप अभी भी इसमें टैग हेडर शायद
नहीं होगा। अभी तक टैग नहीं क्योंकि कॉल
एक्सेप्ट नहीं हुई है। कांटेक्ट हेडर है।
कॉलर आईडी अलग है क्योंकि आपके पास सर्वर
से उसके पास इनवाइट मैसेज गया है। सेम वही
सारे पैराटर्स है। यहां पर वही एसडीपी
प्रोटोकॉल्स है। अब की बार यहां पे भी
ऑडियो पोर्ट इसने डिसाइड किया है। तो ये
सारी चीजें आपको समझ में आ रही होंगी। देन
उसके बाद इसने भी बोला कि ओके इनवाइट
मैसेज गया। उसके बाद 100 ट्राइंग 180 रिंग
इसने उसका रिप्लाई किया फिर से ओके अभी तक
जो आपका क्लाइंट है जो यूजर बी है उसने
अभी तक कॉल उठाया नहीं है इसलिए उसने फिर
से क्या 180 रिंग आपको रिप्लाई कर दिया
फिर क्या हुआ यहां पर 200 ओके यहां पर
क्या किया इसने
क्या किया यहां पर फोन को एक्सेप्ट कर
लिया यहां पर कॉल को पिकअप कर लिया पिकअप
करते ही क्या किया सर्वर ने एकनॉलेजमेंट
दे दिया सो सर्वर ने जैसे एकनॉलेजमेंट दे
दिया सेम टाइम जो 200 ओके एसडीपी था। यह
किसके पास भेजा? सर्वर ने क्लाइंट ए के
पास। उसने बोला ओके फोन पिकअप हो गया है।
उसने एकजमेंट भेजा। उसने फिर अपना सेशन
अपडेट कर लिया क्योंकि जो टाइमर था ना कॉल
टाइमिंग का उसको बढ़ा लिया। उसके बाद 200
ओके फिर से सर्वर ने रिस्पांस कर दिया। तो
यहां तक क्या था? एसडीपी शिप हैंडशक था।
यहां तक क्या था आपका? शिप हैंडशक कि
इनवाइट मैसेज 401 अन ऑथोराइज और यहां यहां
पर जाके आपका कॉल पिकअप हुआ। एकनॉलेजमेंट
फिर से कॉल पिकअप की एक किसको भेजा गया
आपके क्लाइंट ए को आपके 132 को कौन सा
1921 1682 132 को उसके बाद उसने एकजमेंट
किया ये उसके बाद यहां पहली आपकी स्ट्रीम
है ये आपकी ये हेलो व्हाटएवर जो भी पहली
बातचीत हुई यहां से स्टार्ट होती है यहां
पर आपका क्या हुआ शिप हैंडशक के बाद आपकी
फर्स्ट कॉल यहां से स्टार्ट हुई आरटीपी
उसके बाद आरटीपी किसने किया यहां पे
देखोगे किसने सर्वर को भेजा सर्वर ने
किसके पास भेजा? क्लाइंट के उसके पास।
आपके यूजर ए के पास। यूजर बी ने सर्वर को
भेजा। सर्वर ने यूजर ए के पास किया और सर
उसके बाद यूजर ए था। यूजर ए ने सर्वर को
भेजा। मतलब ये दोनों आपस में बातचीत कर
रहे हैं। और ध्यान से देखोगे। कॉल पिकअप
कितने बजे हुई है? यह यहां पर टाइमिंग है।
यह देखोगे यहां पर यह टाइमिंग है। यहां पर
तो 22 सेकंड पे यहां पर कॉल पिकअप हुई है।
और कब तक चली है? यह रहा देखो यहां पर। तो
यह भी 22 है। उसके बाद यहां से कंटिन्यूस
है। यहां पर आपको चार आरटीपी स्ट्रीम
दिखाई दे रही है। लेकिन ऐसा नहीं है।
क्योंकि ध्यान से देखोगे आरटीपी के बाद तो
यहां पर ऊपर भर-भर के आरटीपी स्ट्रीम
होंगी। यहां पर देखोगे तो दीज़ ऑल आर द
देखो इतनी आरटीपी स्ट्रीम है। बट वो एक
स्टैंडर्ड है आपको दिखाने के लिए फ्लो के
अंदर। दीज़ ऑल आर द आरटीपी स्ट्रीम्स जो आप
देख पा रहे हो। दीज़ ऑल आर द आरटीपी
स्ट्रीम्स। इट्स ओके। तो आई होप सबको यह
चीज क्लियर है। एसडीपी हैंडशक क्लियर है
सबको? हैंडशक क्लियर है? सबको हैंडशक
क्लियर है? बताओ जल्दी से चैट में। यह चीज
समझ में आया जो मैंने आपको एक्सप्लेन
किया। अभी सबको प्रैक्टिकली जो चीज मैंने
आपको एक्सप्लेन की सबको समझ में आया नहीं
आया यह बताओ।
बताओ जल्दी से आ गया।
सबको समझ में आया? देयर आर टोटल 15
स्टूडेंट्स। प्लीज जल्दी से बताइए।
सबको क्लियर है?
उसके बाद यह कॉल होगी। कॉल होने के बाद
फिर से किसने कॉल कट कर दिया? किसने कॉल
कट कर दिया?
ध्यान से देखोगे आपके बाय मैसेज गया। 200
ओके बोला ओके कॉल कट 200 ओके बाय मैसेज
200 ओके और यहां से फिर से क्या हो रहा है
आपका कॉल रीरजिस्टर मतलब आपको मैंने बताया
था ना कि कॉल कट हो रहे हैं उसके बाद क्या
है कि इनका एक प्रोसेस है कि वो अपने आप
को रीरजिस्टर करते रहते हैं तो फिर से
रजिस्टर कर लिया कि हम नेक्स्ट कॉल को भी
क्या कर सकते हैं रिसीव कर करने के लिए
रेडी है सेम उसी प्रकार से यूजर ए ने भी
अपने आप को रजिस्टर कर लिया रीरजिस्टर तो
आई होप यह चीज
प्रैक्टिकल करने पर ज्यादा क्लियर होगा।
यह क्या है? मुझे यह बताइए।
हेलो भजिया जो भी आपका नाम है। प्रैक्टिकल
नहीं है ये? दी थ्योरेटिकल
प्रैक्टिकल ही होगा ना यह।
जल्दी से बताना सब लोग।
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग ब्रो।
क्या कहीं प्रैक्टिकल नहीं है?
कई प्रैक्टिकल नहीं है।
सब कुछ प्रैक्टिकली तो है। यह
और ऐसा सोच रहे हो कि लैब सेटअप करना
चाहते हो डोंट वेस्ट योर टाइम कोई फायदा
नहीं होगा।
ओके मिल जाएंगे आपको यह
इट्स ओके मैं आज आई प्रॉमिस आप लोगों को
मिल जाएंगे।
चलिए तो मैं आपको फिर से एक बार क्विक
रिवीजन करवा देता हूं ताकि आप लोगों को
क्लेरिटी हो जाए। तो मैं आपको एक चीज
बताता हूं जो हमने एग्जांपल लिया था वो
एग्जांपल क्या था कि हमने कॉलर ए कॉलर ए
के बीच में भी वायस आर्क का यूज़ किया।
किसके करने उसके ट्रैफिक को कैप्चर करने
के लिए और कॉलर ए और सर्वर के बीच में
ट्रैफिक को कैप्चर करने के लिए वायस आर्क
यूज़ किया। उसी प्रकार से सर्वर और कॉलर
के बीच में भी हमने वॉइस आर का यूज किया।
तब जाके हम ने जो आपको पिकअप फाइल शो की
है जो प्रैक्टिकल्स मैंने आपको शो किया है
पॉसिबल हुआ। बट इन रियल वर्ल्ड सिनेरियो
में क्या होगा? या तो आप क्या कर सकते हो?
कॉलर ए और सर्वर के बीच ट्रैफिक कैप्चर कर
सकते हो या फिर आप कॉलर बी और सर्वर के
बीच ट्रैफिक कैप्चर कर सकते हो। दोनों के
बीच में आप ट्रैफिक कैप्चर नहीं कर सकते।
रियल वर्ल्ड केस सिनेरियो यह हो सकता है।
तो मैं आपको बता देता हूं कि आपको पता है
कि जो यहां पर दिखाई दे रहा है आपको नीचे
की तरफ यह राइट साइड में सॉरी लेफ्ट साइड
में यह आपका कॉलर्स के टाइम स्टैंप होता
है कि कब से किस टाइम पर या कितने सेकंड
पर क्या रजिस्ट्रेशन स्टार्ट हुआ? कब जाके
कॉल स्टार्ट हुई। यहां पर ये क्या है आपका
कॉलर का टाइम स्टैंप है। उसके बाद यहां पर
क्या है? नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट देखोगे कि सबसे
पहले कॉलर ए की रजिस्ट्रेशन प्रोसेस हुई।
कॉलर ए की रजिस्ट्रेशन प्रोसेस हुई। उसके
बाद क्या हुआ?
ओके। क्या है?
दिस इज द रोड मैप। ब्रो। जो जो मैं करवा
रहा हूं ये सब कुछ रोड मैप ही है।
डेडिकेटली फुल कंटेंट है।
ओके। तो उसके बाद क्या है? नेक्स्ट कॉलर
बी के रजिस्ट्रेशन प्रोसेस है। मतलब यह
टाइम स्टैंप यह कॉलर ए की रजिस्ट्रेशन
प्रोसेस। यह कॉलर बी की रजिस्ट्रेशन
प्रोसेस। उसके बाद आपने देखा यह क्या था
कि कॉलर ए ने कॉल किसको किया? कॉलर बी को।
कॉलर ए 1 कॉलिंग टू कॉलर बी 22 2 बट
डायरेक्टली कॉल कर नहीं सकता। तो बीच में
किसका यूज़ किया जा रहा है? सर्वर का यूज
किया जा रहा है। उसके बाद इस पॉइंट पर आकर
क्या किया कि कॉलर ने कॉल को पिक अप पिक
किया। कॉलर ने यहां पर इस पॉइंट पर आकर
कॉल को पिक किया। उसके बाद यहां से ही
आपका क्या हुआ था? कॉल पिक होने के बाद
यहां पर एकनॉलेजमेंट यह सारी चीजें हुई।
और यहां जाके क्या हुआ? आपका यह पूरा क्या
था? आपका शिप हैंडशेक था। यह पूरा आपका
क्या है? शिप हैंडशक है। यह पूरा आपका
क्या है? शिप हैंडशेक। देन उसके बाद क्या
है?
यहां पर आपका आरटीपी ट्रैफिक स्टार्ट हुआ।
उसके बाद यह
तब तक चलता है तब तक रहेगा जब तक कि कॉल
एंड नहीं हो जाए। अगर आप ड्यूरेशन देखोगे
तो यहां पर ध्यान से देख सकते हो।
ड्यूरेंट ड्यूरेशन 26.9 सेकंड। यहां से
देखोगे 22 सेकंड पे स्टार्ट हुई थी और बाय
मैसेज कब आया था? 49 सेकंड। मतलब अराउंड
27 सेकंड तक ये क्या हुई है? कॉलिंग चली
है। तो ये टाइम स्ट देखकर और हम देख के
आईडिया लगा सकते हैं कि ये यहां तक क्या
है? तब आरटीपी कनेक्शन यहां तक वॉइस डाटा
ट्रेवल कर लेता। अब मुझे पता कैसे चलेगा
कि किसने कॉल को कट किया है या किसने कॉल
को एंड किया है। कौन बताएगा? मुझे कैसे
पता चलेगा कि अगर मुझे यह फाइंड आउट करना
है कि इसको देखकर कि किस यूजर ने या किस
कॉलर ने कॉल को कट किया है। प्लीज जल्दी
से चैट में बताइए।
तो टोरेंटो आप एक काम कीजिए मुझे Lindin
पर मैसेज कीजिए टैग कीजिए। ओके
तो प्लीज स्टूडेंट्स कोई भी मेरी Lindin
आईडी यहां पर एक बार शेयर कर दीजिए टैग कर
दीजिए सो दैट कि यह मेरे को मैसेज कर पाए
तो बताइए जल्दी से मुझे आंसर कीजिए
कि मुझे कैसे पता चलेगा कि किस कॉलर ने इस
कॉल को एंड किया है इसको देखकर
बताइए जल्दी से
यस यस बाय मैसेज देखकर क्या देखकर
यह आपकी कॉल टर्मिनेशन प्रोसेस बाय मैसेज
देखकर कॉलर बी ने इसको क्या किया है बाय
मैसेज किया मतलब कॉल किसने कट किया है
कॉलर बी ने जिसने पहले बाय मैसेज की भेजा
तो उसने उसको कॉल टर्मिनेट कर दिया तो ये
सारी चीजें आपको समझ में आ गई कि जो मैं
हाई लेवल पे आपको समझाना चाहता था कि अभी
जो मैंने आपको रिप्रेजेंट किया पीपीटी में
बिल्कुल क्लियर हो गया अगर आपको कोई भी
फाइल फाइल दी जाए एनालिसिस के लिए आप कर
पाओगे
आप कर पाओगे
सब लोग कर पाओगे सब लोग समझ पाओगे इस पे
ऊपर आर्टिकल मिल जाएगा दो आर्टिकल्स और एक
साथ आएंगे डोंट वरी
सब लोग कर पाओगे
भैया बहुत कुछ आने वाला है डोंट वरी बहुत
कुछ आने वाला है कुछ पेड भी आने वाले हैं
वर्कशॉप्स या कुछ पेज कुछ ऐसे छोटे-छोटे
सेशन स्टार्ट होने वाले हैं शॉर्ट टाइम
में हाई क्वालिटी कंटेंट
फॉर योर लाइक योर एक्सपेक्टेशन
वेरी लो अमाउंट पेमेंट
मतलब कम टाइम में कम पेमेंट में क्वालिटी
ज्यादा बिल्कुल जीरो टू एक लेवल और
धीरे-धीरे उसमें हम थोड़ी जो वर्कशॉप
लेंगे वर्कशॉप में भी हम क्या करने वाले
हैं फिर आप लोगों को? प्रीमियम क्वालिटी
के कंटेंट।
डोंट वरी। एवरीथिंग इज इन प्रोग्रेस। बस
आपका काम क्या है कि क्लास में आइए, अटेंड
कीजिए। डेडिकली काम कीजिए। डोंट वेस्ट। यह
वर्क टाइम है एनीवेयर।
ओके। चलो कंटिन्यू करते हैं। नेक्स्ट। अभी
आपको पता है कि कॉलर ए है और कॉलर बी है।
सिर्फ प्लस आरटीपी मतलब इनके बीच में कोई
भी इंक्रिप्शन परफॉर्म नहीं किया जा रहा।
इनके बीच में कोई भी इंक्रिप्शन परफॉर्म
नहीं किया जा रहा। फिर भी मेरा एक सवाल यह
है कि हाउ वी कैन सी दीज़ फोर स्ट्रीम्स?
कि मैंने आपको बोला था कि जब कॉलर ए कॉलर
बी बातचीत करेगा तो हम इन दोनों की जो
ऑडियो स्ट्रीम्स हैं जो चार स्ट्रीम
स्ट्रीम वन, स्ट्रीम टू, स्ट्रीम थ्री,
स्ट्रीम फोर इनको कैसे देख सकते हैं?
कैसे देख सकते हैं? मतलब इंक्रिप्शन नहीं
है बट हाउ वी कैन पहला सवाल यह है। उसके
बाद क्या है? नेक्स्ट एक चीज मैं आपको
हाईलाइट कर रहा हूं। यहां पर यहां देखिए
कॉलर ए है। पोर्ट नंबर 56330
सर्वर का पोर्ट कौन सा यूज़ किया जाता है?
कॉलर टू है 51019
बल्ब में जो जो आपको हाईलाइट कर रहा हूं
देखना। नेक्स्ट
यहां पर देखोगे इनवाइट में भी 56 यह पोर्ट
नंबर है। 56 जो है पोर्ट नंबर है। उसके
बाद 51 0019 यह पोर्ट नंबर है। यह चीज
आपको दिखाई दे रही होंगी। नेक्स्ट यह
देखो। बट जो रेड में आपको दिखाई दे रहे
हैं और ब्लैक में जो आपको दिखाई दे रहा
है। हाउ
अभी तक तो 56330 पोर्ट पे काम चल रहा था।
इधर से 560 को यूज़ किया जा रहा था। सडनली
यहां पर 4000 यहां पर 17004 या 4000
इनको कैसे पता चला? और फिर से अगर आप
देखोगे अगेन नीचे से ये रहा 56330
फिर से 5060 बट जो ब्लैक में आपको दिखाई
दे रहे हैं। हाउ कैसे? यह पोर्ट बदले
कैसे? और इन दोनों को पता कैसे चला?
कैसे पता चला?
बताओ कैसे पता चला?
बताइए कैसे पता चला?
ओके।
कुंडू बोल रहे हैं सर सीटीएफ बनाइए।
सीटीएफ टीम आप लोगों को सीटीएफ भी चाहिए
हमारे कंटेंट के बेस पे बताओ हम
कंटीन्यूअसली जैसे ही कोर्स एंड होगा
कंटीन्यूसली
हम ईजी टू हार्ड लेवल के 20 टू 50 सीटीएफ
कंटीन्यूअसली कर लेंगे। आप लोगों को
आईडिया मिल जाए सीटीएफ कैसे सॉल्व होते
हैं और आपके कांसेप्ट भी क्लियर हो
जाएंगे।
बट मेरा सवाल यह है कि कम्युनिकेशन
स्टार्ट स्टार्ट हुआ आरटीपी प्रोटोकॉल में
बट इनके पोर्ट चेंज कैसे हो गए?
इनके पोर्ट चेंज कैसे हो गए? किसी को याद
आ रहा है?
नेक्स्ट कम्युनिकेशन के लिए पोर्ट कैसे
पता चले इनको?
क्लियर? मैं आप लोगों से जो पूछ रहा हूं।
कैसे पता चले? जल्दी बताइए।
बताओ बताओ बताओ
किसी को कोई भी आईडिया एनीवन हैव एनी
आईडिया
कोई गेस कर सकता है
इसको गेस करने का वह है कि पोर्ट
नेगोशिएशन ड्यूरिंग एसडीपी प्रोसेस मतलब
जब आपने इनवाइट
जब आपने क्या किया था जो इनवाइट मैसेज
भेजा था जो इनवाइट मेथड का यूज़ किया था तो
आपने देखा था एसडीपी
वहीं पर क्या होता है कि यूजर ए और सर्वर
और सर्वर और यूजर बी की बात करें उन दोनों
को डिसाइड करना पड़ता है एसडीपी प्रोसेस
के दौरान कि हम हमारा जो आरटीपी का
कम्युनिकेशन है वह हम किस पोर्ट के थ्रू
करने वाले हैं। मतलब कि यूजर ए बताता है
कि मैं ऑडियो यहां पर यूजर ए बोल रहा है
कि मैं सर्वर को बोल रहा है कि मैं आरटीपी
कम्युनिकेशन के लिए या आरटीपी ऑडियो
स्ट्रीम के लिए पोर्ट 4000 का यूज करूंगा।
मैंने आपको बताया था मीडिया डिस्क्रिप्शन
अगर याद है पैकेट एनालिसिस में तो वहां पर
क्लियरली बताया था कि मैं पोर्ट 4000 का
यूज़ करने वाला हूं और सर्वर ने बोला था कि
मैं पोर्ट 12 2662 का यूज़ करने वाला हूं।
वहीं पर जब सर्वर और इसके बीच में यह रहा
देखो यह रहा यहां पर इसी के अंदर यहां
पोर्ट नेगोशिएशन हुआ था यहां पर कि यह
4000 का यूज़ करेगा और यह इस पोर्ट का यूज़
करेगा और यहीं पर जब सर्वर ने यूजर बी को
भेजा तब बी से यह पोर्ट नेगोशिएशन हुआ था
कि ओके इसने बोला कि मैं 12262 का यूज़
करूंगा। फिर जब यहां पर एसडीपी ओके 200
एसडीपी आया था। उन्होंने अपना भी मीडिया
डिस्क्रिप्शन दिया था। तो तब इसने बोला था
कि मेरे को मीडिया आरटीपी कम्युनिकेशन के
पोर्ट 4000 यूज कीजिए। पोर्ट 4000 यूज
कीजिए। इसीलिए क्या होता है? यूजर एंड
सर्वर बी सर्वर मस्ट नेगोशिएट वि आरटीपी
पोर्ट दे विल यूज़ यूजर बी एंड सर्वर
परफॉर्म सेपरेट नेगोशिएशन एंड दिस
नेगोशिएशन ऑकर्स थ्रू एसडीपी सेशन
डिस्क्रिप्शन प्रोटोकॉल। अगर आप देखना
चाहते हो तो यह रहा आपका यहां पर।
यह रहा। अगर मैं आपको दिखाऊं तो आप देख
पाओगे यह आपका सेशन डिस्क्रिप्शन
प्रोटोकॉल यह रहा एसडीपी और यहां पर आप
देखोगे तो यहां पर यह आपका मैसेज हेडर
मैसेज ये रहा एसडीपी यहां पे पोर्ट कौन सा
यह रहा ऑडियो पोर्ट मीडिया पोर्ट 4000
वहीं पर अगर हम पैकेट एनालिसिस देखेंगे हम
किसका इसने जब सर्वर से एसडीपी का रिप्लाई
आया अभी तक नहीं आया था तो इसने सर्वर को
बता दिया सर्वर ने किसको भेजा यह रहा
एसडीपी सर्वर ने किसको किसको भेजा था?
यूजर बी को। तो सर्वर देखना इसका इसने
क्या बताया?
ओके। मीडिया पोर्ट कौन सा मीडिया पोर्ट
बताया था?7474
उसके बाद देखोगे देन उसके बाद
174 किया था। हां बिल्कुल 174
उसके बाद यहीं पर इसने रिप्लाई क्या किया
था सर्वर को? यह रहा। सर्वर को रिप्लाई जब
किया तो हम देख सकते हैं यहां पर जब सर्वर
को रिप्लाई किया था सर्वर को उसने कौन सा
पोर्ट बताया था 4000 पोर्ट किसने यूजर बी
ने और जब सर्वर ने किसको रिप्लाई किया था
इसका कि मुझे कम्युनिकेशन करने के लिए कौन
सा पोर्ट यूज़ करना है किसको यूजर ए को तो
देखोगे तो उसने यूजर ए को क्या बताया था
कि मीडिया पोर्ट कौन सा यूज़ करना है
62 का यूज करना है तो इन्होंने आपस में सब
कुछ बताया है ओके और यहीं पे इन्होंने
यूज़ भी किया है देखो यहां पे इन्होंने
यूज भी किया है। इसने 174 को यूज़ किया।
इसने यहां पर 12262 को यूज़ किया। इन्होंने
अपने हिसाब से अलग-अलग पोर्ट को यूज़ किया
है। क्लियर गाइज़? एक चीज क्लियर हो गई।
बात रही वो चार ऑडियो स्ट्रीम की। वो चार
ऑडियो स्ट्रीम कहां गई? क्लियर? इसको बंद
कर देता हूं। गो टू टेलीफोनी गो टू
आरटीपी। आरटीपी स्ट्रीम देखो यह वो चार
ऑडियो स्ट्रीम है। 1 2 3 4 ये आपकी चार
ऑडियो स्ट्रीम है। यह है आपकी वो चार
ऑडियो स्ट्रीम। समझ में आ गया? ये आपकी वो
स्ट्रीम वन, स्ट्रीम टू, स्ट्रीम थ्री,
स्ट्रीम फोर। ये आपकी वो चार ऑडियो
स्ट्रीम है। क्लियर ये चीज? ये चीज क्लियर
है?
अभी मैं ऑडियो को एक्सट्रैक्ट करना सिखाता
हूं आपको कि ऑडियो को कैसे एक्सट्रैक्ट कर
सकते हैं। एक तो आप क्या कर सकते हो? वs
से ही एक्सट्रैक्ट कर सकते हो। जो पहली
टेक्निक है, पहली टेक्निक है कि आप इसी से
एक्सट्रैक्ट कर सकते हो। कैसे यहां पर
जाके कि एक तो ये चारों स्ट्रीम खुली हुई
है। कंट्रोल ऑल सिलेक्टेड है। देन यहां पर
आप क्या कर सकते हो? प्ले स्ट्रीम। यहां
पर क्या कर सकते हो? प्ले स्ट्रीम। जब
यहां पर आप प्ले स्ट्रीम करोगे तो ये आपको
दिखाई दे रहा होगा। देखता हूं कि आपको
सुनाई देगा नहीं देगा। लेकिन y एक्स आर
ज्यादा फिजिबल नहीं है। क्यों? यह फिजिबल
इसलिए नहीं है क्योंकि इसमें बफरिंग होती
है। तो चलो देखते हैं कि काम करेगा नहीं।
सो हम यहां पर प्ले करते हैं। अभी ये हां
अभी प्ले करते हैं। बताना
दिस इज कॉलर वन। वेलकम टू पटेस्ट एकडमी।
दिस
वेलकम
किसी को ऑडियो सुनाई दी
किसी को ऑडियो सुनाई दी जल्दी से बताओ
सुनाई दिया सबको
सबको सुनाई लिया ऑडियो एक्सट्रैक्ट करना आ
गया सिर्फ और आरटीपी से फर्स्ट मेथड तो यह
था और बता देता हूं कैसे कर सकते हैं ठीक
है एक तो मेथड यह है एक और बता देता हूं
इसमें और कैसे कर सकते हो इसको क्लोज करते
हैं ओके इसको क्लोज करते हैं देन टेलीफोनी
शिफ्ट फ्लो फिर से कंट्रोल ऑल यहां पर भी
आप क्या कर सकते हो प्ले स्ट्रीम कर सकते
हो यहां पर भी आप प्ले स्ट्रीम कर सकते हो
और देखो
दिस इज कॉलर वन वेलकम टू पिस्टर एकडमी
दिस इज
वेलकम टूमी
तो ये भी सुनाई दिया होगा प्लीज प्लीज कोई
भी मेरा Lindin प्रोफाइल एक बार ग्रुप में
शेयर कर दो यहां पर चैट में प्लीज जल्दी
से जो भी मेरे पास Lindin पर है प्लीज कोई
भी भेज दो जगत गुरु जी या कोई भी एक बार
मेरी Lindin प्रोफाइल यहां पर शेयर कर दो
ओके तो यह हो गया एक ये चीज हो गई दूसरा
और और भी कई तरीके हैं। एक और व एक्स में
एक और तरीका है। हम कौन सा यूज़ कर सकते
हैं? देखो यहां पर आप क्या करोगे? इसको एक
बार क्लोज करता हूं। यहां पर क्लोज कर
दिया। फिर से आप क्या टेलीफ़ोनी पर जाना
है। टेलीफ़ोनी पर जाने के बाद आपको क्या
जाना है? आरटीपी स्ट्रीम टेलीफ़ोनी पे जाना
है आपको आरटीपी स्ट्रीम आरटीपी स्ट्रीम
क्लिक किया आरटीपी स्ट्रीम करने के बाद आप
क्या कर सकते हो आपने सबसे पहले इस पे
क्लिक करना है वन बाय वन तो इस पे क्लिक
करते ही आपने सेलेक्ट करना है एनालाइज पे
यहां पर जाओगे आप एनालाइज जैसे एनालाइज पे
क्लिक करोगे तो ये ओपन हो गया एनालाइज पे
क्लिक करने के बाद आपको क्या करना है इसको
सेव करना है एनालाइज पर क्लिक करने के बाद
आपको क्या करना है इसको को
सेव करना है तो एक्सपोर्ट
ओके
टू प्ले इट
एनालाइज एंड इसमें ग्राफ देखें तो इट्स
ओके फाइन
से ऑप्शन देयर और नॉट
नो
सेव
ओके नो नो नो नो नो नो यहां पर ऑप्शन नहीं
आ रहा कॉपी एक्सपोर्ट क्लोज एनालाइज पे
जाएंगे तो ओके फ़्टर प्ले स्ट्रीम कोई नहीं
हमारे पास और भी तरीका है चलो इसको हटाते
हैं हमें इस पे नहीं मिल रहा है तो तो हम
एक काम करते हैं इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं
और इसको भी हम क्लोज कर देते हैं अभी आपको
क्या करना है ब्राउज़र में जाना है ब्राउज़र
में जाने के बाद आपको क्या करना है वेट
वेट वेट वेट ओके ब्राउज़र में जाने के बाद
आपको क्या करना है? एक होता है आपका हम
पिक कैप टू वेव पिक कैप टू वेव हिट एंटर
ये रहा। यहां पर फर्स्ट क्लिक पे लिंक पे
जाना है। फर्स्ट लिंक पे जाओगे आप। मैं
इसको आपके पास शेयर कर देता हूं। कंट्रोल
सी और आप इसको शेयर सेव कर लीजिए।
कंट्रोल वी ये रहा आपको मिल गया लिंक। और
यहां पर आपको क्या करना है? ऐड फाइल। यहां
पर आपको क्या करना है? ऐड फाइल। फाइल मैं
कहां से ऐड कर सकता हूं? मैं फाइल यहां पर
ऐड कर सकता हूं। यार
डेस्कटॉप यह रहा एसआरटीपी ये रहा नॉर्मल
कॉल टू पार्टीज और यह रहा नॉर्मल कॉल टू
पार्टीज। यह ओपन करते हैं। यहां पर जब से
हम ओपन कर दिया उसके बाद यह रहा यह चार
वन 2
यह रहा। इसको हम क्या कर अभी डाउनलोड कर
रहे हैं। डाउनलोड कर लिया और इसको मैं ओपन
करता हूं। प्ले जस्ट वंस
सुनो।
दिस इज कॉलर टू वेलकम टू पटेस्ट अडमी
सबको सुनाई दिया
सबको सुनाई दिया बिल्कुल बताओ
दूसरी ऑडियो को भी देखोगे आप ये रहा।
बिल्कुल। इसको भी ओपन करते हैं हम।
दिस इज कॉलर वन। वेलकम टू पेंटिस्ट एकडमी।
सुनाई दिया सबको यह भी
बिल्कुल तो इस तरीके से एक ये दो दो तरीके
पता चल गए आप लोगों को कैसे ऑडियो स्ट्रीम
को एक्सट्रैक्ट करते हैं दो तरीके पता चल
गए आप लोगों को दो टेक्निक पता चल गई
और भी टेक्निक्स हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में
बताऊंगा मैं आपको ऑडियो स्ट्रीम उसके बाद
हम वॉइस मेल के बारे में भी देखने वाले
हैं। कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल के बारे में भी देखने
वाले हैं। तो जो भी दो तीन टेक्निक्स हैं
नेक्स्ट क्लास में बात करेंगे। यहां तक
सबको क्लियर हो गया?
यहां तक सबको क्लियर हो गया? सबको समझ में
आ गया?
आज का टॉपिक क्लियर है सबको?
आज का टॉपिक सबको क्लियर है? बताइए जल्दी
से।
आज के सेशन में मजा आया
गाइस यू एंजॉय इट
तो आई होप ये चीज आप लोग कर पाओगे
कर पाओगे ओके
किसी का कोई डाउट है क्लास में तो पूछ
सकता है।
Lindin पर आप मुझसे मैसेज कर सकते हो और
आई विल डेफिनेटली
आपको मैसेज का रिप्लाई करूंगा। हो सकता है
कि आज नहीं करूं लेकिन कल कल तक कर दूंगा
मैं।
माय lindin इज ओपन और नॉट
माय lindin इज नॉट लॉग्ड इन तो सो आई एम
सॉरी बट मेरी जो Lindin प्रोफाइल होगी मे
बी किसी को नहीं पता यहां पर
तुम डेफ्रोनिक्स पर हो
डेफोनिक्स एकडमी में फॉलो करोगे तो मेरी
प्रोफाइल मिल जाएगी वहां पर सचिन सर तो एज
एज अ सीईओ तो वहां पर एक काम करो मेरे को
रिक्वेस्ट भेज देना। आई विल एक्सेप्ट एंड
यू कैन फॉलो इट डायरेक्टली। आई विल
एक्सेप्ट योर रिक्वेस्ट। प्लीज टेल मी योर
नेम देन ओनली आई विल टेक योर रिक्वेस्ट।
वंश कुमार ओके तो श्योर टैग मी lindin तो
आप सबसे पहले
डेफोनस एकडमी
इस पे जाइए lindin प्रोफाइल इसको फॉलो
कीजिए फॉलो करने के बाद वहां पर जो
फॉलोवर्स में फॉलोइंग जो डेफिनेट्स मुझे
भी फॉलो करता है तो उसमें मैं मिल जाऊंगा
और वहां पर सचिन सर या सचिन नाम से जो भी
आईडी मिलेगी एज ए सीईओ तो आप मुझे टो कर
सकते हो फॉलो कर सकते हो रिक्वेस्ट भेज
सकते हो आई विल डेफिनेटली वंश कुमार आई
रिमेंबर तो आई विल एक्सेप्ट योर रिक्वेस्ट
तो किसी को कोई डाउट है तो पूछ लीजिए
अदरवाइज सेशन को एंड करते हैं और नेक्स्ट
सेशन जल्दी से जल्दी से जल्दी ले आएंगे
नेक्स्ट सेशन भी जैसे रेडी हो जाएगा कल
परसों हम सेशन को लेकर आ जाएंगे ओके
बट रिमेंबर गाइस पढ़ लो बिकॉज़ एग्जाम विल
बी नॉट इजी इट विल बी सो हार्ड
ओके
तो चलिए फिर अगर किसी का कोई भी डाउट नहीं
है तो सेशन को एंड करें।
ओके तो थैंक यू गाइस। बाय-ब एंड सी यू फॉर
नेक्स्ट सेशन। जल्दी नेक्स्ट सेशन में
मिलते हैं एक और नए टॉपिक और एक और नए
कांसेप्ट के साथ या जो अभी आपको पता है कि
हमारा सेशन क्या होता है? हमेशा नया ही
होता है। तो बाय-ब टेक केयर एंड गुड नाइट
एवरीवन।